il mime surveille dans la neige jusque
là le blizzard blizzard blizzard moi
j'ai dit bizarre vous avez dit bizarre
tiens comme c'est bizarre j'arrive
devant la porte d'un igloo le tout à
l'igloo je frappe à la porte de l'igloo
vous avez déjà frappé la porte d'un
igloo quand la neige est molle vous
allez braves qui passe au travers
l'intérieur il ya d'esquimaux un
primitif qui voit dépasser une maille
entrée j'entre atmosphère glaciale
où puis-je m'asseoir sur la banquise est
ce que vous devez savoir will paul pour
les 1000 à victor c'est ça de la part de
la part de blizzard
bizarre bizarre moi j'ai dit bizarre
comme c'est bizarre incident et est apte
vous avez du feu alors l'autre primitif
avec un glaçon dans chaque main jim
singh si ça ne prend pas qui ment ça n'a
pas pris heureusement que j'aime et
amulettes
alors l'autre primitif éteignez vos
cigarettes vous allez faire fondre la
maison vous avez fait un trou dans la
moquette